moi je dis depuis trois mois ici
ailleurs que j'ai lu les données
statistiques anglaise et qu'il n'y a pas
de formes plus grave du variant anglais
non mais c'est les données hospitalières
anglaise je ne comprenais pas comment
c'était possible je vais laisser
m'attends tout à coup deux études
viennent de paraître chez les biens
familiaux personnes viennent de paraître
bien constater les coups qui disent ah
bon c'est peut-être trompé en fait le
barrio anglais n'est peut-être pas si
dangereux que sans réelle et le
dérailleur brésilien pour vous est-ce
qu'il est dangereux creux n'en sais rien
hoffenheim est aussi je ne sais pas ça
il faut anticiper mais non violent à
milan mais d'abord on évite de parler
d'un état qu'on ne connaît pas et ils
vont mettre division là vous n'avez
jamais été autant cinglé que vous avez
non mais attendez attendez vous parlez
anglais vous parler portugais vous nous
parlez de bonnut moyenne 3 et puis on
vous a parlé de vous mais par les mots
lancés brésilien des cas de réinfection
elysées ce club à sa réussite et l'épi
les gens qui ont été vaccinés les
quelques instants
oui ranger votre dossier où il rien
dedans risée du monde entier à quelqu'un
qui sait le par les fabricants dont on
peut venir ici c'est vous n'annoncez je
vais vous dire pourquoi on peut rire je
vous ne savez rien parce que vous ne
connaissez rien et que vous êtes là
juste effectivement profond de la bo
d'animation et un peu de buzz
la vérité c'est qu'effectivement vous
lui avez très justement dit des gens
meurent on est parfaitement et attendait
et aux gens qui meurent il ya une chose
qu'on doit c'est la vérité oui mais
c'est pas parce qu'il eut des morts du
copil qu'il faut qu'elle est mort de
peur ces premières premièrement et
deuxièmement bon c'est pas en affolant
les populations que vous allez réussir à
régler quoi que ce soit monsieur j'ai
aujourd'hui le problème que vous avez
sur vos plateaux c'est que vous racontez
n'importe quoi que j'aime beaucoup
ludovic mais il te dit que se présentent
à vous avec des données qui sont
partielles avec des données qui ne sont
pas les données de la science alors volé
ou à montpellier quoi moi ce que je
ferai la première vous dire je n'ai
je recommande ce que recommandent les
épidémiologistes en pareille matière
parce que c'est pas la première épidémie
qu'on traverse c'est exactement de faire
ce qu'on fait à venise au moyen-âge
salle et nous ça vient le mot isolés par
la console isolé cette saga
ça vient d'eux isola qu est une île
parce qu'au moyen âge ils sont là nos
mises en fait mais les délais les gens
qui arrivaient en mettez donc arriver
aujourd'hui ce qu'on pourrait faire
c'est correctement de paix israël
les gens qui viennent en france et bien
effectivement on les soumet un test pcr
on les met en quarantaine en france
faire puisqu'on sait pas si il est en
avant pour les notes quarantaine en
france on le fait et on arrête de
commenter et on arrête d'affoler les
populations et on arrête de dire le
variant angles est le mari ensuite
brésilien le marion nord-américain est
vachement plus grave il va tous mourir
fois les rôles et si l'on peut avoir d
un temps ça c'est bon pour l'audimat
c'est bon pour les chaînes d'info mais
derrière il ya des gens qui meurent ou
là il ya des gens qui jouent à trouille
mais alors jamais donné